so let's jump into this breaking news
that actually just broke right before
the show started we have this from
Bloomberg markets just in First Republic
Bank the San Francisco based lender that
was cut to junk by s p and fetch is
exploring strategic options including a
sale
let me break that down for you a sale
means they are about to fall apart
what's happening right now with Silicon
Valley Bank in this major collapse that
the federal government is stepping in
and they are trying to sell it off
they've ensured all deposits svb
apparently put out a statement where
they're like it's the safest place to
have your money because the government
has insured all deposits with no caps so
it's like Funny Money Monopoly money yo
if this is how they're viewing the
system there ain't no system there is no
system so we were going to talk about
this other Story look at this one
Dow closes more than 250 points lower as
Bank crisis spreads to Europe live
updates is from CNBC and they're talking
about Credit Suisse according to one of
their uh main investor guys or main
companies
there's no money left
there's no money and the Saudis which
apparently are principal investors
saying they can't give any more because
of regulations so it's looking like
credit Suite which is a very large
International Bank is on the verge of
collapsing this was already predicted
the bond market apparently is is doing
very very poorly and we've talked about
that in the past week so uh as we're
talking about this right before the show
starts feels like atem First Republic
Bank is trying to sell now to another SF
bank so this is going to be the fifth
bank we've got silvergate was the first
most people didn't know or didn't care
because it wasn't that big but
silvergate collapses then what happened
was because of that Silicon Valley Bank
brought the statement about raising
money and it caused a panic everybody
said is this going to be like silvergate
I don't want to lose my money so they do
a there's a run in the bank Silicon
Valley bank then falls apart then
Signature Bank falls apart some people
are trying to claim that that bank was
better but I don't know all I know is
that's three banks that fell and now we
have credit Suites in the First Republic
on the chopping block yep so I don't
know I'm going to defer to Max Kaiser uh
Economist did he say the end is nine he
said he tweeted out about four hours ago
a global bank reset is coming all
depositors will have their deposits
protected this is Max Kaiser uh all your
deposits we protected he's saying he
says the US dollar and other Fiat money
will be swapped for a central bank
digital currency and depositors will be
given a bonus amount of the new currency
when the switch is made you got to make
this to sweeten the deal like a quick
version of the Euro switch he he
concludes uh terrifying but I I see the
plan I mean he knows he's seen this for
about a decade in the making he's in El
Salvador you know hanging out with the
president and pushing Bitcoin as the
national currency I like him a lot but
the thing about Perma Bears is Perma
bears are Perma Bears so when bad times
come they look like they're Geniuses
because they're Perma Bears you know
it's like like they're all yeah
permanently bare like he's he's
permanently bearish on on uh fiat
currency he's permanently bearish on
he's right
I also I also am against I am also
against the the structure of our uh our
uh Fiat system currently I agree but can
I just say if I had listened to Max
Kaiser like 10 years ago I'd be I'd be
very happy person living on my own
private island because he was like Tim
I'm telling you you gotta buy because
point right now and I was like I got a
little bit I'm not worried about it oh
you gotta buy more and then Tim is
fibbing to you because Tim could live on
his own Island right now that's not true
that's not true max Kaiser this is his
own Island this is this is kind of like
having your own Island it's amazing
coming out here it is a Mountaintop yeah
to be fair yeah
we're at your own Island I mean there's
like people who live close by and it's
it's not like mountains you know in the
Rockies it's it's the it's the smoky
it's the Blue Ridge you know they're
beautiful it's a bunch of dirt there's
no minerals in it nothing like that yeah
you have your own Harem of chickens uh
well that's Roberto Jr's Harem he's a
very busy man but uh no no in all
seriousness uh so I have the tweet for
Max Kaiser that uh Ian was referencing
where he says a global bank reset is
coming and a lot of people think this is
to bring about a central bank digital
currency which is going to be the
government's crypto which they control
and the reason they'll do this is
because they can track every single
purchase everything you ever do like
before the show we were talking about
this and it's like if you want to go buy
gasoline on Thursday but that day is not
good for ESG they're gonna say you know
what your Central Bank coin doesn't work
at the gas station today
say bye to your gun purchases that's
right they're already I mean they're
they're beta testing this with the
credit cards yeah oh yeah was the the
first step towards digital currency now
you now you're swiping a card it's funny
because futuristic sci-fi and video
games always had this we've envisioned
this play video game and it's like a guy
in the future goes how many how many you
know Union credits and that's what they
would call it Union credits and then
they would just have like a wrist watch
and they would beep and that's where we
are in a way it's more secure because it
can't be stolen from your pocket but in
the other way it's completely insecure
because someone else well they can turn
it off yeah like literally they can it's
programmable money they're going to be
able to say this money is for this and
then you have other money that you can
use for other things so there will be
luxury money like you'll have money for
leisure time that you're allowed to
spend at the movies or downloading stuff
or whatever then you'll have like
Necessities money Etc and different like
if you have a low ESG score you won't
get a lot of credits for uh for luxury
and Leisure those will be the ones to
entice people like remember in uh what
was it the uh The Fifth Element the
cigarettes that that they were given out
like they were re mostly filter just a
little bit of Sarah in them that kind of
control is the future if we get a a
central bank it's now it's now we've
already seen in in like Denver where
they were like you can't turn on your
air conditioning in the in the AC locked
or in I think California they were like
you can't charge your electric car what
about South Africa where they're like
you have no right to electricity oh you
thought you had electricity rights in
South Africa nope government doesn't
have to constitutionally provide you
electricity figure out your own build
your own electricity yeah Thomas Edison
I'm actually thinking about that because
we have a small Creek on the property
and I'm like can we trench this and then
put a water wheel in there
yeah you generate generate some power
and he says he doesn't live in his own
Island come on yeah it's a big plot of
land right West Virginia batteries to
you'll want to get the batteries to
store it that's really the the storage
is the thing because and then what
happens is overnight it charges a decent
amount you'll probably drain all of it
very quickly because a water wheel is
not gonna it's not a fast-moving River
so yeah I mean in Florida you get these
guys coming up knocking on your door all
the time I live in Tampa and they're
like yo look at your house it's great
can we put solar panels up on the top
and we'll give you this much money
because the power companies pay us for
your solar panels
have you done it I have not done it I
think it's a really good idea for you to
do this I'd rather do it for myself
right right so I have a generator so I
have an uh so I have an L like a
generator right that runs on gas LP yeah
and so when the when the hurricane hit
my generator kicked on it's awesome uh
and but what if someone cuts off the gas
line they can't cut off the sun I don't
think so maybe solar is the way get
tanks get LP tanks I got a thousand
gallon yeah I think and I'm gonna get
two more and I need to get uh someone in
New England that can install house
batteries like Tesla house batteries I
can't find anyone anyone out there in
New England that installs house
batteries in Southern New England hit me
up where should they hit us a long time
on my Twitter we went with a different
company we we tried doing Tesla at first
and that just took too long it was a
disaster a year later they showed up
with the stuff and we were like dude we
just don't want to we're with someone
else I got the solar now and I I like it
they they I put a new roof on last year
and they came they took the solar panels
off so I could put the new roof on no
problem no issues but I can't find
someone that'll actually like your solar
panels I do yeah yeah I do I really want
to get the uh you get to keep the energy
or do you have to sell part of it to the
power company I right now I have to sell
it back because I don't have the
batteries because it's New England and
there's not a lot of sun in there but
you get like credits yep so like social
credits so here let me let me show you
this is It's the platform or the basis
for it let me show you this real quick
this is from the mod fool why are Wells
Fargo and Citigroup falling today and I
don't really care to get into the
details I just want to then show you
this story this is from well uh Seeking
Alpha Wells Fargo no crisis here
well okay so you get to decide for
yourselves whether or not you think the
end is an eye because uh I'll put it
this way
right before the show starts to get
breaking news another bank is in serious
trouble and you're gonna hear from the
Jim cramers and from the bidens all
they're all going to say everything is
fine your deposits are safe don't worry
about it
Maybe
but I don't know how much I trust these
guys that's the problem because I feel
like when they come out and say don't
worry everything's fine they're actually
having the inverse impact they think
they are everyone's going to hear that
and be like Run for the Hills
get your money out of the banks
people don't like hearing Banks being
like it's all fine
nobody don't pay attention the little
man behind the curtain what does the
four four of America's biggest banks
lost to combine 55 billion today on
Thursday that's today yeah no that was
today's Wednesday that last week last
week yeah last week jeez
well I don't trust anyone to live your
life for you that's some advice take
care of yourself and use your brand yeah
I imagine this is like we you were
talking about it the other day Tim I
imagine this is not the end of the
problems that we've got that coming I
think that these the bank failures here
are gonna I think that it's probably
gonna lead to more stress in the system
I don't I'm not predicting it you know a
crash because I have no way of
predicting the future at all and I'm not
you know I'm not a a an economics guy
but it's not a bad idea to get your self
squared away so that way you have you
know some Necessities if you're able the
scary thing now is the time the scary
the scariest thing is that people who
want the system to fail will
intentionally go out and take all their
money out of the banks thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks bring it out and we'll see you
all next time